you're welcome to this video playing
vampire from Greece two three 12.5 mm
yeah the Pantheon II which amazingly has
been played by a magnus carlsen recently
in in vikon's ii yeah Bishop b5 is the
old line here and it's basically a
refuted line 25 this is excellent for
black but you tend to forget those lines
at least them I I must admit that I tend
to forget it 3g - yeah the ship f6 track
takes check no I think it's King d8 in
the edges
yeah this is some a line that I have
from presented in my my video series
about a 45 is black I have a dedicated
video on the Ponciano
and if I would have a perfect memory I
would just need to recite all this and
then win the game but it's not not so
easy I mean to remember to remember
stuff okay he can take the rook but then
I take H one here this is answered by
Bishop h3 by now I remembered at least a
bit of it he can now take the rook with
check all this is very violent of course
but it's if it's working what what can
you do
Queen takes King e7 in the and those
games by Magnus Carlsen they played
three Knight f6 Knight f6 instead of d5
against d5 Queen a force however play
will lose this is probably what Carlson
would have played what I don't really
get this what is why doing if he plays
this opening and he places incorrect
line yeah I would assume that he at
least knows it like just yeah accepting
okay it's it's not it's not really it's
not really a good line but let's let's
hope that the opponent doesn't know what
and so on but he just plays it like he
just sees this position for the first
time which is quite honey
okay so Bishop to e3 yes the idea and
then f8
yeah there is some point about that okay
so if I take Bishop III check
yeah quite quite remarkable position
yeah he's Bishop III check
okay yeah you do
okay to d7 or well I always have this
this chicken okay so we grab that should
i give the cheque boys to something
better
mmm yeah he's threatening to take on g7
yeah probably I made some mistake along
the way it's always a bit annoying if
you know that what is what the opponent
is doing is complete bonkers but you
forgot how to hit it and it's not easy
with two minutes or something okay so
the check on d3
I don't really have a maid
check okay yeah maybe III Bishop f5 this
kind of stuff if he takes on h8 my DS
Bishop f5 and Quincy two minutes check
yeah so I'm going here I think if it
takes Bishop f5 is really just winning
Queen f2 us was deadly I know Queen c2
ik and again looks the bishop of course
but ok I have I have fun I have the pawn
taking on earth-2 what what the wacky
position this is really crazy
oh wait wait wait wait not so fast
okay I need to do that threaten made so
he the rook is still gone
I can I can give this single check it's
not it's not more
Quinn's yeah you can actually forgot
about that I have the shack as well
Bishop d7 threatens King b6 checkmate
almost made what a crazy game when his
rook is also lost I mean down to 22
seconds what deck
and this Pepsi two-time morning my scope
is protecting that
Wow yeah and it's just you can just win
now with Quincy four or anything check
so pretty easy even check
no no trick maybe there was something
yeah I've known Jamie I can't win all
the time I didn't see it
okay so let's check this Wow yeah okay
this was completely mad
yeah probably what the heck
so what the heck did I do one f6 or what
Bishop f5 is the winner yeah and I
forgot and Trinity forgot how to win and
to win this
yeah he is writing to me yeah this
should be five is the move that wins I
have forgot it I simply forgot it there
should be five intending III yeah it is
a freight is basically a forced win this
opening for black button okay but f6 is
really bad yeah after f3 yeah it seems
the computer gives why the winning edge
and this is of course pure tactical I
wasn't I wasn't really remembering
things right
okay okay and after that it is it is
check yeah and it's winning for what
yeah white wins wins the whole the whole
King side and I have only some some wake
cheating chances but here III is the
winner yeah yeah it's it's difficult
check yes i he's putting up some moves
here to to analyze it seems that he
really doesn't know that this line is
lost for white but it's it simply it's
really but okay that's know if you know
it's a gamble I mean I have six
yem yem he was lucky the other than that
I didn't didn't know the the writings or
forgot it I had analyzed it for this
video but this is such a rare opening
you you tend to forget things something
like like that is just winning like can
escape here and the problem is his King
is some this is is really dead here
check
something like this threatening almost
made yeah okay an entertaining game
nevertheless thanks for watching